this is important for everybody I wanted
to take a moment and identify some of
the principles about art and business
that hopefully you can apply to what you
do or what you want to do in life Nick
and I are on a side quest to pick up my
custom 1967 Ford f100 truck which has
been in the shop for the last six months
[Music]
hey man welcome to Jake's corner where
we learn about things sometimes I rant
about things but other times we learn
about there's a lot of information out
there about how you can learn a craft
and turn that craft into a business or
learn any passion for that matter and
turn it into a business and so I wanted
to take a moment and identify some of
the principles about art and business
that we apply that hopefully you can
apply to what you do or what you want to
do in life rule number one you must
identify what your product is if you
don't know what you're selling okay
let's just go back right there I don't
like to think of things as selling I
like to think of it as what you're
contributing to the world we're all
selling things in life to live in the
economy that we live in but in order to
improve the world at the same time you
need to consider what you're contributed
videos that's what we do that's what we
make that's how we make our living rule
number one understand what your product
is rule number two understand why it's
valuable to other people not just to
yourself it's obviously very important
that it's valuable to yourself but
understand why it's valuable to other
people that's gonna help you understand
how to get it in front of other people
for us entertainment is the value that
we bring in our product which is videos
what makes something entertaining that's
a little subjective for who you are as a
creator but to us creating learning
teaching exploring trying new things
having fun those are the philosophies
that we like to employ here on the
salmon eco channel and
have been proven to be entertaining to
other people and we know that because we
look at and we read the comments and we
read the emails that you guys send to us
and we read the notes that you sent us
with the fan art we communicate we have
that conversation and it's super helpful
it's really fun that's the first two
principles understand what your product
is and understand what the value of that
product is to other people if you can't
figure that out well then look deep into
your soul and work for somebody else and
you're having trouble identifying what
that is well then you need to spend some
more time on a spiritual side quest to
understand what in your heart makes you
happy in life that can take a short time
that can take a long time keep at it
you'll find a way I recently moved away
from downtown I no longer live in
downtown so that means sometimes if I
don't bring a lunch I have to go out and
get lunch driving a car in downtown
sucks because of the traffic so I had a
great time riding that little electronic
bike around downtown until one fateful
day when I took a BB to the skull we all
remember it far too clearly
[Applause]
and then Christian wrote off on that
electric bike this is for the studio
this is for people who wanted make a
quick errands want to go out and snag
like a little sandwich or something so
this isn't yours no I got this because
it's awesome having an electric bike at
the studio this video is not sponsored
by this electric bike but if you like
the bike there's a link below maybe I
think we can all just take a moment to
respect a nice pair of shears amazon
link below good pair of shears
let's make this a video about shears
instead of this bike shears
we've got like roughly a five inch blade
length compare that to your normal pair
of like Fiskars she's like off-brand
they're not even fists what is it look
at that blade length
have you considered drilling a hole in
there and seeing if those actually work
better are you suggesting that I can
drill a hole into this No so the thing
with shears is a really heavy-duty kill
this feel the weight Oh
this weighs at least a pound and a half
if you want to chop some at least two
pounds you wanna chop some let's
get back to the spice this this segment
is going nowhere bike this bike is
shaped like a normal bike when you're
brining in the ebike you want to feel
future if they can you that means you
want to cool straight frame why not have
style points but I'm hoping the
performance why are you jealous that's
why I am participating in this segment I
don't get where this jealousy is coming
from maybe you just leave this to me
right I put together a lot of bikes I
took these testosterone pills and I lost
all this chin hair and it kind of puffed
out there oh well obviously it's a
three-quarter 8 micro meters what size
rented that 15 anyone who knows that
account knows that isn't building things
fun he's been having a lot of fun right
now I can't handle it I had my fingers
slammed in a doorframe
like maybe three months ago and it was
like one of the most painful experiences
mileage 24 miles 18 miles an hour 24
miles that's pretty solid maximum speed
is a little slow put your butt on it
Raley is all bent up and it is
it's actually straight up damaged
yeah earlier doesn't work okay well no
one's riding this bike top-down on that
yeah this bike is done it would be
perfectly straight yeah this is all
kinds of bent up oh my god well to
anyone who wants to send us a working
with your bike please do that's like the
basis of whatever
see how this little cover that is on the
derailleur is warped okay yeah this is
pushed inward
I want to be able to do that by pedaling
or pulling or putting tension on it
something somehow I bought this it was
like this before we pulled it out of the
box is this the sort of damage you can
get from transit inside the box Art's
actually were pressed up against the
edges yeah actually yeah look there's a
pretty decent impact here this could
have been hit anyways that's the end of
this segment
good thing we had our Sears as the
backup segment I found these extra media
pairs like like a tractors here this is
the one you just want to pin something
and rip it like someone's fingered in
pitch and really
pinch twist rip is important for
everybody after you understand what your
product is and what the value of that
product is to other people you want to
understand how to work with people
outside of your business in order to get
your product in front of other people
don't be afraid to say no
to other people don't be afraid to turn
people down the people that you will
eventually end up working with that you
will enjoy working with the most that
will bring the most value to the table
and that you will work with continually
again and again our few and far between
and so when you find a good partner in
anything keep that person that means
you're going to go through a lot of
people's and it's not that other people
are bad at business some of them are but
some of them are some of them are great
it's just that their brand doesn't work
with what your brand is and that's
totally ok it's important to understand
that when I say brand here I'm not
necessarily talking about McDonald's or
coca-cola I'm talking more high-concept
oneself you know the way that you hold
yourself out there in business is your
brand and that's true whether you're an
artist
a Salesman engineer that is effectively
an easy way to refer to it and so I'm
gonna refer to that here for example our
product in and of itself is videos so if
somebody comes along and they want us to
make cars well obviously we're not fit
to work with that person I think you
understand what I mean
when you're looking for other people to
work with how do you hone in on who is
the right person and what makes a good
deal is this fair is this fair how do
you choose partners our brand the
corridor digital brand or Sam Nico or
the people or the fun we have in those
videos that is the character of the
video content the brand's or the other
partners who support us whether or not
it's an actual brand Star Wars or it's
Nick who came over and did the
card-throwing but the way that we look
at that in our product is that's the
stage you've got the stage and you've
got the characters where the characters
and everyone else is the stage and this
helps ensure that the videos are
entertaining throughout the context and
it allows us to work with the right
people very often we run into people who
want to make their brands the character
they want the video to be about coffee
cups now that I'm the character I'm
gonna keep you guys entertained look get
this out of here but at the same time if
they came along and they said we make
delicious coffee that gets you jacked
out for the day tastes wonderful you're
gonna love it so we go and
something with that understanding like
this is the context that's making this
video possible such as Nick with the
cards none of us can do card tricks so
he came over here and he made that video
possible it wouldn't have been
entertaining if it was just him
performing his stuff on our channel
first and foremost
by a train by a train and leave it in
your yard it's actually in law the
attractive nuisance doctrine if you
leave a train in your yard it's an
attractive nuisance and a child make
wander over to it because they're
mesmerized by it and if they get hurt on
that train even if it's on your property
and you have a keep out sign it's still
your fault as it's an attractive
nuisance remember the principles are
very simple first and foremost
understand what you or brand is what you
contribute to the world know what your
product is and know the value that it
has to other people in order to get your
brand and your product in front of more
people know what to look for in your
partners your brand is the character and
the people that you work with are the
stage or vice versa you can be the stage
for other people those are the
principles we apply we think it works
well if you have any things that you
think we can do to improve on this or
things that you apply in your own life
that you think could be beneficial to
those other people watching this throw
them in the comments and if all of the
journey consider subscribing seventy
Kotaku youtube.com slash Sam and Nika
Sam what if we did this what if we
removed the chain apparently so that
yeah you can't write it anymore but
because it's electrical power we're
still writing this almost like
that one song
[Music]
[Applause]
it works great dude it's like et's bike
dude it's like et's by again makes you
fly you just imagine yourself flying and
it go this is a electric bicycle without
a chain here no one's touching it this
is the invisible bike chain
revolutionize
[Music]
[Applause]
hey I'm gonna drive today Nick and I are
on a side quest to pick up my custom
1967 Ford f100 truck which has been in
the shop for the last six months it's
been the shop for six months because
it's an old boy and you don't just bring
an old boy to any corner mechanic who's
a new boy you got to bring him to
somebody that's truly an artist he
basically has taken my truck apart and
put it back together I called him the
other day he told me it would be done
today I've been calling him this morning
I haven't been able to get ahold of him
the shop line has been busy I think he's
just super slammed right now
I used this truck all the time for
productions that we do and for the last
six months I've been having to rent a
truck and every time we do productions
and it's been costing a lot of money
well we have one tomorrow that we're
doing we need it back he said it would
be done today let's go down there let's
check it out small that says Watson on
it that mine
[Music]
damnit
ah yeah it sure is a shopping thing
that's gonna be ready I don't know I
honestly don't know thing about owning a
vehicle like this is that it's not a
regular car where you buy it it runs and
a nice salad
these are constantly in need of
something they're never 100% you just
have to kind of accommodate for that
it's gonna be okay
you think so dude I'm just so nervous
we've been apart or six months I don't
know who she's gonna be anymore
you know she's been through a lot I've
been through a lot I don't know what our
relationships gonna be like I mean I
know where we came from I know the
foundation that we have was strong but I
mean I hope so
you know I hope that that spark comes
back yeah
Niko destroyed my iPhone with an arrow
he forfeited burritos to everyone each
for your iPhone I will bequeath you a
burrito
q.q yes the taco truck makes really good
very house
okay look I know here at Stephens makes
good burritos actually Stevens is my
favorite sandwich restaurant in LA
[Music]
are we taking the back road never Jones
actor dude it's it's funny feels like
you're about to be like mobbed by
Raiders
[Music]
all Vella is my favorite sandwich
restaurant it's great
[Music]
I would tweet about the Rideau day but I
don't have a phone you burrito this is a
chorizo burrito cheese and let me tell
ya they do chorizo right here sometimes
you get really greasy cheese oh is it
better than Starbucks trees on the
scrambled eggs
[Music]
much better
I don't eat there but it's probably
better countries those lymph node
[Music]
really